I am back. Why am I back at 7 p.m.?
I'm back at 700 p.m. because robotics
doesn't make any sense. So, we're going
to see if I can help fix that.
Here were the current experiments. Um,
what is the best way of doing this? See,
trying to think if we should just go to
a harder problem.
You know, let me look at a couple
things. Let me just look at a couple,
right?
We'll decide
like this thing. You can understand why
it's a pain, right?
Oh,
this is Wait.
Okay,
look at their baselines.
We'll decide from there. Welcome, Twitch
folks.
Where did my chat go?
back under the camera.
We're going to hope that the stream is
stable because uh I don't know what the
weather's doing outside. We've had like
three different micro bursts in the last
two hours.
So
got pick cube,
got push cube.
And see this one is slightly harder.
Yes.
And push t
much much longer.
Jack cube
even harder.
Then where is it? Peg insertion.
That is like a concerning gale outside.
Holy.
I hope I don't lose my roof. I've got a
lot of nice hardware in here.
All right.
So, the hypothesis here is that
hopefully
our setup scales
to higher task complexity better than
theirs does, even though it's kind of
difficult for us to like speedrun the
super simple tasks.
That's the hope.
Why are we seeing all those successes at
the start?
Something is weird.
Definitely weird.
Yeah, our return graphs are not going to
be comparable either.
Have a
show zero success
for quite a while.
Something's very weird with these
returns.
fact that we're getting like success
probs on this
wonky.
Hey, if it works though, it'll work.
Like, if it works, it works. We'll see.
Okay, we're starting to get like an
actual curve.
We're seeing it on return as well. Very
weird how noisy it is.
I really didn't mess with very much
either.
How long does it take them to solve this
task?
Wall clock.
Oh, they actually have it in like five
minutes. Okay, not that bad then.
one looks like we could do it faster
potentially. Oh, you know what?
Actually, I I do see here that they have
a bunch of like
solve rates before it catches.
Okay, that's not bad.
if this works, we can maybe do the uh
peg insertion task.
That cube has like a really stupid
looking return curve.
That could just be the reward function
to be fair.
least it's a good thing that we're
actually like solving these tasks,
right? Keep in mind, none of this stuff
was set up for robotics. We don't even
have that many M's with continuous
action.
The fact that we're kind of just like
doing robotics out of the box is already
pretty dang good.
It'll get better with optimization,
right?
I could try to get 2048 to work locally
in the meantime
It's actually we'll not do it on my
local. We'll do it on uh on Puffer Max.
Okay. So, this is 2048. This will run
over here. And uh it looks like this is
improving. Yes.
probably. We do just have to tune
everything.
So, I mean, here's an interesting
question, right?
How do we tune everything?
when it has to be multiGPU like this.
Like I can't even run all the M's on one
GPU.
Be fair, we don't have to do this all at
once, right? Technically, I can punt on
this and just like say we'll get some
mostly policies to start with
and then we come back once we have
multiGPU sweeps.
That's a fine approach.
Also, it looks like 2048 is working now.
I think I set this to 40 mil. So, I
think we should be good for
quite a bit.
What's the speed?
O, slow. 140k. 150k.
Are they just like really sample
efficient or something?
Yeah, they just solve this in 20 mil,
huh?
There's something wrong if they're
solving it in that many fewer steps,
though.
Well,
we would expect what, naively? 120 mil.
Do we get it in 120 mil?
It doesn't look like we're even going to
do it in 120 mil, right?
Cuz like that would be the naive worst
case.
Hey, that guy. Welcome. We're doing some
robotics.
Their hypers are really screwy though,
right?
Let me take a look at their hypers
again.
They probably just have like these
absolutely cranked
hypers.
Uh, looks like 2048 is solved as well.
We'll go pull that policy in a second.
Can do that now real quick.
Welcome.
by 150
not working.
you conquer robotics. I mean, we have
some stuff working on robotics.
Here's 2048.
Although I was reading about OpenMP
parallel processing gum.
So you're just reading about everything
in everything in existence.
Welcome
Going to get stuck here
about 10:24.
Ah, yeah. Screwed up.
Average uh average run should get 2048
though.
You have No, I do not have a CNC
machine.
I don't know how any of those things in
that sentence go together either.
Where's my Rubik's Cube end, man? The
Rubik's cube end.
I would be like ridiculous. I'm sure.
Oh, that's kind of interesting how it
did that, right? It's got 1024 512 20
256 trying to stack 20 uh 10. It's
trying to stack in the corner. It's not
fully working, but Oh, yeah. There it
goes. There's 2048.
See that it's got 2048
text is not offset correctly.
Welcome Magid. Yes. Again today the work
is never done.
Okay, we need some colors and we need to
fix that text.
Grab my color palette from here.
Do a puffer 2048.
probably
[Music]
I do read. What are you talking to me or
Georgie?
An iPhone is not a $150 to build either.
Not true.
Literally the components in their raw
form cost more than that.
That looks like vibe coding.
Um, if color picking is vibe coding,
then sure. I'm not allowed to freaking I
mean, I could technically go try to
interpolate the thing. I'm just seeing
if this gives me anything remotely
decent.
This doesn't look like it will. We'll
see.
I the thing is I don't know if this is
actually going to be correct.
You have to like not hue shift stuff.
My M score becomes flat. Agent is still
not learning.
What env are you using and what score do
you get
to give you an update?
Uh, I probably could do that to be fair.
I guess I don't like copying things from
the LM always messes with other things,
but yes, I could totally have just done
that just with this one piece.
Pong, let me give details.
Yeah, Pong literally learns in three
seconds.
I think the demo No, the demo shouldn't
be spotty for that one. Should be very
consistent. I know it doesn't log as
frequently as I would like, but that's
the only thing weird with it because it
doesn't output enough logs.
Oh, look. It didn't give me enough
colors.
It literally didn't give me enough
Uh
10inut expert policy verse 52 posted on
X. Let me go grab that.
Wow, it doesn't even show me your post,
man. That's sad.
Holy
crap.
I've literally never seen that in my
life.
Uh
horizontal lightning
like
freaking
like sawtooth wave. Holy.
Yeah. Okay.
our whole code base. Yeah, you're not do
you don't do that in Popper Lib.
You don't copy and paste the code for
Yeah, you're not allowed to do that in
Popper LIIB. We get very mad. All right.
I mean, this is like a decent policy,
but like it kind of took forever.
It does solve.
What's the next the next hardest one?
or stack cube.
We'll try stack cube
Oh, got to download the new Discord
update manually. One second.
Copying the entirety of GitHub on Puffer
Lib.
Wait, copying the entirety.
Oh, you're joking. Yeah. No.
Stupid PR like stupid PRs will be
rejected and you will be flamed.
where did you post this into Discord?
Yeah, there's something in here. Oh,
it stops learning because the task is
solved. I don't know what to tell you.
Like the training curve flattens out
because the task is solved. It says
performance is one, four is 20.
You're just not loading it correctly if
you're not seeing it playing the game.
agent not able to play well. Are you
loading the model
like eval load model path latest?
I will do it for you just to show you.
Just give me a second. I will show you
this thing learning
ride with name path
here. Puffer crane. up for a pawn.
Okay, it's trained. That's how long it
took.
It plays perfectly.
Did you not realize what paddle it is?
Like you're the you are the blue one.
This works for you as well. So what what
doesn't work? What environment doesn't
work?
It's 0 to nine. Blue has scored 10
points.
I can see I can see it winning as well.
The yours yours always blue loses
environment inside. I Yeah, I don't
know. Well, the thing is it's possible
that there is like a platform specific
loading bug though, right?
It's always a thing you can do being
here.
We'll need to get some better colors
picked.
I bet
always working.
Uh, let me see.
We need better colors.
This is the um
Yeah, it's just like a a hue thing.
Does the original go through multiple
color shades?
I don't think so. Right. It's just like
it goes from like white to uh
There's no vibe coding here, man. I
don't know what you're on about.
Even like the new programmers around
here will do stuff correctly.
of course. Well, I'm looking at this
here and I'm seeing it's like one shade,
isn't it? Does it just go to like red
with 2048 or does it go through multiple
shades?
Hey, how's it going?
Good. How are you? I'm all right.
Working on a few different things.
I'm muting for you today, but that's
being
uh you your voice is like super super
warped. Can't really understand what
you're saying.
Like the microphone.
Let me see.
is is is now good. Yeah, it's a bit
better.
Yeah. So, today I think uh I was uh
waiting for you the morning but looks
like you start late today. So, yeah,
that that's what I'm saying. I had to
write that article.
Yeah. Yeah. Now you you told that.
So basically what I am facing you know
so I I try sweep for pong you know to go
through all the things
but you know when I it's kind of uh
training one by one and every time it's
it go at top and flat the curve
but when I try to load it's kind of uh
looks like it's not lining because most
of the time blue loses but when I
execute your command like puff train
um you know environment and things so
that's when it's kind of actually
learning and learning pretty first well
sweep is going to get you sweep is going
to run a whole bunch of experiments
and then the idea is that you go grab
the optimal hyperparameters
from the p the specific experiment that
you want, right?
Like if you just load random experiments
from the sweep, they may or may not be
any good
because the sweep not every experiment
in the sweep is going to work well.
That's the point of it, right? Is that
it tries a whole bunch of different
things. If you just go like load some
random stuff from the beep may or may
not be good.
But the one it you know reaches the
maximum and flattening out that should
work. Yes. But then how did you go get
that policy? You like go find like the
name and Neptune and then the name
locally or what did you do?
Uh I find the name locally and uh trying
to run but it's
not working.
And it shows as one. Does the show go as
like that experiment that you loaded
shows as one
like PF is one? Uh
can you repeat again what the experiment
that you load for the experiment that
you loaded uh in the sweep does it show
as having performance one?
What's the um so I mean there there are
a few different metrics you can look at
there, right? Like there's a there's a
score metric. The score metric is going
to be different for every game or every
environment, right? There's a lot of the
environments have a perf metric which we
do to try to make your life easier. We
try to add a zero to one normalized uh
indicator of performance. You just know
that like one is good, zero is bad,
right? We try to make it very easy in
that way. So for pong, one means you're
getting all the points, right? And in in
the case of Pong, like the maximum score
is 20, the maximum perf is one. These
two things mean the same thing.
Uh can I share my screen to you know get
Yeah. better.
Let me share my screen.
Hey permission.
What? Uh
so I'm using Mac. So it's it's uh
yeah I don't have permission. Let me
there's no there are no permission
settings in Discord that I have to give
you be able to. No no it's on Mac
actually. Um
it's a very painful when you try to use
new application you have to give all the
permission. Oh yeah,
So,
yeah. So uh so the learn 15 is the one
that I
executed with your command like with uh
buffer CLI. Hang on. And it is actually
pretty good. It's it's the best best
um settings I would say. I'm looking at
these.
So I see
uh almost all of those look like they
work.
Yeah. Let's say um
yeah 15 is is I know it's working
because it's uh it's using the CLA but
let's say um
second one
this is also good right
looks like it. Yeah. Yeah. If
if I try. So I'm still, you know, using
the sweep to test it out like the one
running now. I think Yeah. Is it
I think 16 also kind of a you know it's
flattened out.
Well, it's Yeah, it's trained like
I can't tell exactly. It looks like
looks like that's a solved run.
Mhm. So, let me um I open it.
This is different.
Uh
it's uh experiments and
learn 16.
I'm ID guys, so maybe you won't like it,
but yeah,
you're allowed to use an I don't care if
people use an ID. That's fine as long as
they don't submit the garbage AI
generated code.
it's not completed yet because there's a
model in there. You could load
this one. Yeah.
is is
you can just copy the path.
Wow. Something's changed.
Something has changed between those two.
Like I don't know if that's not a model
for the same environment or something.
Uh okay. I think now it will run because
uh it just finished.
So I I didn't use anything uh like
custom. I just you know ran you know the
command mentioned on the yeah docs.
So if I hit right now see
Good work.
Oh, really?
Okay.
the current model. Oh, it's a it's it's
a it's a snake. You're running snake. I
I
Uh, for some reason Oh, yeah. It's super
slow for me. I like I get
Yeah. So, as out of 16,
why am I not seeing Are you seeing it
play or are you getting like one frame
every like like 10 seconds?
I have no idea. Like, oh, now it's doing
so. Hang on.
Mhm. Uh,
Oh. Um, okay.
Is there a frame skip parameter
difference?
So when you ran sweep, part of the sweep
is the frame skip.
I didn't do any sort of uh Yeah, but
like like it'll do it for you. So if you
look at your config,
okay,
you look at the phone config.
You know where that is?
Here 16. No, I'm well. Yes, you can look
at that first. Go to 16.
That'll work. And now look for frame
skip.
namescape uh four or no it's two the 16
yeah four okay four now if you go into
uh well I guess you can just you're
doing it from CLI you can just do d-m
frame skip four and you load the policy
and see what happens
any order
Okay.
It's got to be end of frame skip.
I think. Yeah, that's the Now it's
aggressive.
There you go. So, literally all that
happened, all that happened here, right,
is that you got this sweep and the sweep
includes parameters of the environment
and then you didn't apply them. You
trained it, you tried to evaluate a
model in a completely different setting
from what it was trained for.
Okay. Oh, yeah. So, this is uh good to
know. So, I didn't know that. So, you
know, some of the environments have
parameters like this, right? where like
there's a part of the environment
configuration itself that is a part of
the search and uh you just essentially
have to be careful to look at your
config parameters and make sure that you
know you're actually evaluating in the
same setting and you'll it'll be pretty
obvious right like stuff like this
you'll see that it will not work and
obviously you haven't really done much
in puffer so you would not know this
right but things in puffer generally
work and they work very very well when
they're not working usually there's some
gap
Yeah, gap of learning.
So I I I'm actually pretty impressed
with Puffer
to be honest because you know so for
it's it's it was pretty hard you know if
I compare 100 times you know. Oh yeah,
it's part is is like pretty easy and
fast. Man, I suffered with uh I suffered
through RLIB for like years in part of
my PhD. Like there's a reason that we
have stuff built the way that it is,
right?
And it's it's built from uh
there was a lot of pain and suffering
that was gone through order to make all
this stuff work the way it is.
Oh, it's a yeah, I was pretty impressed
to be honest. Yeah, I even I cannot
think like you know my learning rate is
kind of exponential right now because
everything is working and I'm confident.
Well, I mean it's you'll have to get
deeper into stuff at at some point,
right? Um but hey, there are a lot of of
course. Yeah, I'm just, you know, I'm
just learning and uh it's kind of a noob
in this space, but yeah, we have lots of
new people around in the probably I I'll
I'll I'll catch up like I know few
member on Discord. They're they're
pretty advanced, but yeah, I'll I'll try
to catch up them.
Thank you. Yeah, I hope you enjoy.
Of course. Of course. I I literally
every day so I I got notification when
you get into live. I try I try to stream
as much I try to stream as much as I
can. I do I also have other work that I
have to handle outside of just the live
stream. So sometimes I get delayed but
yeah generally this is what I do.
Yeah. No, it's it's I it's it's pretty
pretty good and it will be a pretty big
platform one day. I wish. I hope so.
Right.
No, thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
All right, that was cool.
And yeah, thank you for the reminder,
bet. Folks, do star the repository. It's
free. It helps me out a lot. Star the
puffer stars. Uh, we're about to get
this environment that was added by a new
contributor onto the website hopefully
quite soon here.
Fortunately, this didn't work, right?
the job.
Okay, we're going to see right here
whether this uh cleans up the nice
graphics for us.
Okay, what do we think about this for
the environment?
What's the goal? It's 2048.
The name of the game is 2048. The goal
is to make 2048.
numbers are not like centered
reasonably. I think
Reduce the animations doesn't suffer.
What do you reduce? What animation?
There isn't any animation.
Oh, the speed. Yeah, the speed's going
to be slower than that. Don't worry.
That's just what happens when you run it
through like eval at max speed.
I'll let somebody else decide to like
clean this up a little bit more. But
is this a basic neural net?
If this is a basic neural net, we can
like port this thing to see and have
this on the website in 10 minutes.
Wait.
Oh, it's just a CNN.
Not even one hotted.
Like a basic CNN.
I think we can probably do that
relatively quickly then.
This is fine. I thought it was 5 million
grams and I was going to be mad. Totally
fine.
So, we're exporting these weights to a
binary format. We can load them from C.
How to get to a level so one can create
such a large research project alone
alone like create puffer lab alone. I've
been doing this since I was 16
and really not all that much else.
How can I contribute if I'm not advanced
as you? That is absolutely something you
so on puffer.ai
we have a quick start guide for
beginners
uh on the blog.
This covers a lot of the basics in the
intuition.
And then pretty much what we suggest all
newcomers do is uh go to the docs
and follow this tutorial to write a
basic environment that will give you a
lot of the intuitions.
This is Yeah. So pretty much it's just
like come up with an interesting
environment, something that you can do
in a few hundred lines of code max and
implement it. You have plenty of
examples on the uh the website, right?
You have plenty of examples here of
things people have built.
You know, it's actually kind of funny.
If you're a creative, sometimes you can
come up with simple things that look
really cool, like Tetris.
Tetris is a pretty simple game, but look
how awesome this is to watch.
This is like mesmerizing.
There you go. Also, like I made this
thing. This thing was really simple to
make. This is really cool to watch.
And then we have environments that are
like, you know, useful in various ways
for research.
We had a couple of students make this.
This is really awesome. This is a drone
flying in.
This is like a more math heavy thing,
but engineering wise is not particularly
crazy if you know the math.
Which recent project on the pup are you
expecting
hear a feedback on?
Well, I wouldn't like
What recent project are you expecting
back on?
Um I mean I'm not going to like tell you
to do the same thing as somebody else is
already working on. Right.
I have to say I've been playing with it
for the last couple of days.
Let me think of like some good stuff.
There's several environments that people
are still developing at the moment.
I don't have like a like an infinite
list of just cool things in my head,
right?
It has nothing to do with reinforcement
learning to like come up with like a a
cool thing that you think would be
interesting to do.
Like, let me think. If I could like
think of like a basic thing for somebody
new right now, what would I think?
I mean, I don't know, man. Like, we some
of the most simple things are not going
to be as interesting to look at. So,
usually, honestly, the best thing for
new people is to pick like a simple
arcade game. Like, pick one of the
easier to implement Atari games. there
like so many of them like or one of like
the classic arcade games or something of
that form like pick one of the easier
ones and do that like that's usually a
good call.
If you have other suggestions that's
good as well.
Double cart pole
like double pendulum cart pole. That's
going to actually be too hard for them.
You actually need to know physics to get
the math right.
I'm in love with RL and chemistry.
Actually, that is a key thing that we're
interested in right now. Like real world
applications of RL. If you have domain
knowledge in another area like chem and
you see an opportunity for a sim, that
is like top top tier. Most people don't
have that. So, if you actually see
something you can do in chem, like go at
it. That's awesome.
I have lots of other domain knowledge
bet. You know that we've been trying to
do more industry stuff for a long time
and you know I've been watching like
random chem and physics stuff like
compulsively for the last few weeks.
Where can we find Ray Leari games? On
the website and also in Puffer Lib. You
know, we got Breakout, we got Pong, got
Pac-Man, Freeway, Tetris, Enduro.
We train an RL agent to learn how to
talk to women.
Dude, that's a much easier problem. Like
I You don't even need RL for that. All
right.
Thanks and lot and I definitely will
don't have a supervisor here and people
can correct me in my cam plus RL. You do
though because just join the discord.
Like there are a ton of people on there
who have like gone through intro RL
stuff through puffer lib who will be
more than happy to help you. Uh when I'm
not and I'm also like I stream for some
ungodly number of hours per week.
My policy has gone through catastrophic
forgetting and not recovering for that.
I you got to fix that, man. I don't know
what to tell you. It's not that hard.
Don't be a doofus.
Raleigh, Flappy Bird, Flappy Puff. Yeah,
that's a basic environment somebody can
make. That should be super easy as a
starter project.
Swimming fish. Exactly. That That's an
awesome name.
Good job. Yeah. Call it swimming fish.
Just don't llm. Yes. If you generate if
you generate if you just generate the
entire end with an LLM and ask me to
review it, I'm going to be mad because
don't ask me to spend my time reviewing
code that you haven't actually put any
effort into learning anything else,
right?
Like ultimately the point of reviewing
really simple M's where like you know we
don't mind pring really really simple
M's they're cool but ultimately the
point is that hopefully we have people
learn something and go on to like build
bigger things that are really going to
help with research right you actually
have to learn from that doesn't mean you
can't use LLMs for anything you see that
like I have autocomplete in here right
like if I do like this I have
autocomplete but If I'm like, if you're
autocompleting like this much code at a
time, you're doing something wrong cuz
you're not learning [ __ ] Especially if
you're new.
That's the one thing that pisses me off
because we've had like multiple weekl
long bugs uh introduced by people like
submitting LLM garbage
that will get you flamed a lot.
I can't quite do a a Torvold level rant,
but I will aspire to do my best.
you be open to discussing RO plus chem
papers?
Yeah, you don't need to create a new
channel. You can just post stuff. I
don't like making tons of channels
because like what ends up happening is
like, oh no, the one channel's too
disorganized. Let's make another one.
And then you just end up with two
disorganized channels.
might have trouble. No, bet. We are very
interested in chem. Like we are very
very interested in chem. Chem and like
material science stuff especially. I
actually really want to figure out ways
to do like actual industry grade sims in
these areas. And I'm like I've actually
been slowly studying uh chemistry and a
few other related areas on my own
offstream.
like absolutely
in fact that's like literally probably
the most valuable thing uh is if you are
actually like if you actually do have
good domain knowledge in another area of
science and you can find a way to bring
RL into it. That's like I mean that's
like how you could help us like actually
I mean, that's how you get involved with
like even the business side of Puffer,
frankly,
because that's exactly the type of stuff
we're looking to do.
This offer is open to you as well, B.
Like, generally the way Puffer works,
it's not VC funded, right? This is
bootstrapped. So if you want to be
involved with like the business side of
Puffer, which is a mix of like
fundamental RL research and like solving
actual problems in industry,
like opening up doors in industry for
things that we can build really awesome
sims and apply RL to is how you do that.
Let me join your channel. It's public,
man. Discord.gg/puffer
are interested on Fed contracts.
Uh, I mean, we're, yeah, we're
interested in government contracts.
There are a couple areas where that
makes more sense than others. We're
definitely open to that type of stuff.
It's ultimately just about like finding
different areas in the real world where
we can apply RL and then of course that
funds all the cool research that we do.
Like machines aren't cheap.
Do you Yeah. I mean, we're we have a
couple things we're working on that
could very easily turn into DoD
contracts. We don't have any at the
moment. Uh any DoD contracts
specifically? We have other contracts.
That's tomorrow.
Sure.
Yeah, send me a send me a DM if you have
like contacts or you have like ideas.
We have a few avenues we're pursuing at
the moment.
Small molecule mechanistic pathway
predictions.
That's totally spot on. Like no, that's
good, man. Like any sort of small
molecule sims
are going to be a really good match with
RL. the bigger the molecules get uh
likely the more computationally
inefficient it's going to be and the
harder it's going to be to RL. So like
literally we are looking for areas in
chem and material like basically any of
the like actual hard sciences, right?
We're looking for areas where we can
build SIMs and solve actually useful
problems.
Have you managed to look up 25? Now data
is no problem. Comp cam research.
Density
functional recalculate
Yeah, the trick is figuring out how to
leverage the existing data because like
in reinforcement learning, right,
typically the whole the whole shtick is
that your data comes from a SIM and if
you can build a fast SIM for something,
you can probably reinforcement learn it.
And then the like the question is
basically how high fidelity does your
sim have to be in order for you to
actually solve the thing you care about.
Did you see I don't know if you saw the
article I published today. I publish
articles on X
just the main spot I distribute stuff
but we did RL on a pabyte of data and
that pabyte of data just came from sim.
This is like one of the recent things we
did.
The orca stats.
What is that?
What are the orca stats? I don't know
what that means.
High performance quantum chemistry
programming pack. That sounds awesome.
20 to 30 atoms and elements.
Okay, this is really cool, huh?
Oh, this is from fair.
This is very cool.
I've actually been I did it's quantum.
I've been studying quantum uh I've been
studying basic quantum as well.
like a third of the way through the
first MIT course in quantum.
Six billion CPU hours is some crazy
amount of compute.
What What orca am I looking at?
I like I don't know what that is.
Yeah, I you can you can feel free to
link them in the Discord. I like I don't
know what I'm looking for.
I don't I don't have background in this
area.
can see the data set properties. Okay.
One second.
I should not lose internet. We'll see.
But just FYI, there's like a crazy
lightning storm outside.
Quantum chemical data sets
Very cool.
Yeah, man. This is like the exact type
of stuff I'm interested in.
Access
Unless you have background on like
actually completing those, they don't
exactly just work like whoever the hell
applies for them and gets them.
They're very often earmarked. It's not
like it's really not like an open fair
market on those.
They're planning to submit this.
Oh, if you work in this base and you've
secured a bunch of contracts previously,
that's a different story.
lot of contracts
then yeah there's possibly a business
opportunity there because like I know a
bunch of different groups that have
basically done uh similar SBIS in these
area but they don't get phase two or
phase three right because they don't
have the technical background so that is
something that we could actually assist
Looks like not just military but private
contracting nonetheless. Yeah.
Cool.
if we do have other viewers in industry
that uh same thing kind of goes right I
stream all this work it's all free
you're free to use puffer lib in
whatever capacity you want personal
academic or commercial
but uh if you really want to like get
the best that we can provide in RL. We
do have services available.
Okay, so these have to be copied.
I figured I would just like get this
policy onto the website tonight if I
can.
I try to keep dev slightly cleaner for
like updates, but of course nobody
respects that.
What's your plan for Fourth of July?
I don't really have one. I think my
family is going to be happens to be in
the area though, so I don't know. We'll
probably do something
reminding me
I did not finish my sets for today.
Getting late. One second.
Freaking grip is harder than the lift
coming to DC. Nah,
wasn't planning on it.
DC is probably a
a mad house on the 4th of July. I know.
I like my peace and quiet when I can get
it.
We'll see if this solves the
environment. But and so far this is like
at least doing something.
This could actually be a reasonably good
benchmark environment cuz like it's very
fast and it seems like it actually takes
a decent number of steps to learn.
See, it's stuff like this where it's
like people just make random
environments
and like some of them end up just being
really useful for research.
Like the fact that this actually seems
learnable with a very simple policy but
it takes a very long time is just
fundamentally interesting, right?
Hello to all the YouTube and Twitch
folks. Very popular stream day it seems.
I am trying to be more consistently live
every day. Well, except Sundays.
I take Sunday off for the most part.
It does look like this is not quite
going to get there though, huh?
If I just run this for 4 billion, will
it just solve?
Or 5 billion?
If I just run this for like five billion
steps,
that would be useful because it would
still go on the website and it would
give us like a thing to work off of.
So 1482 by default.
Let's do puffer
export.
posted in the general.
Okay, give me one second. I will be
right back. Let me use a restroom and I
will come check out all the things and
also try to get this on the website
tonight if I can.
let's see what chemistry we have to look
at.
I'm the chem plus RL guy. Welcome. First
is a transformer model using RL to
predict mechanism of reactions.
Yeah, supervised stuff.
Comp research using symmetric gradient
domain ML
any model again comp with 13 million
data points.
So the thing that I'm wondering about
and I will look at these references
that'll take me a while. Um, the thing
I'm wondering, Arin, is
has anybody tried to do like RL in the
loop of a sim with Comp Cam?
Now, I know that a lot of the Sims are
very, very slow,
but I'm wondering like to what extent
that you make useful fast Sims that
would tell you enough to actually be
able to like RL something, right?
That's kind of the name of the game in
RL is can you make a fast sim?
And I would think for at least certain
aspects of chemistry, you should be able
to
like stuff like this.
Was this MIT?
Oh, and these are nicely annotated for
me. Perfect.
Yeah, I will have to read through these
when I'm fresh, though. I've kind of
been going like all day.
I add things to my reading list to read
when I'm like actually have brain cells
to spare.
We will leave this guy on the other
monitor and hopefully it'll solve.
Meanwhile,
So sometimes what they do is they create
a neural net for each atom to simulate
the end change around them and MD. Yeah,
I you know I've been talking to people
that want to go that route as well.
Um
I'm always pretty hesitant to like
replace the SIM with a neural net.
Like is it possible? Yeah, maybe.
I kind of wonder if we can just do like
a fast sim and rlet.
What I should look for in molecular sims
with RL. So look, generally
reinforcement learning is an interaction
process, right? You control some aspect
via some action space. you have
something that can take M's, whether
that's steering a molecule or like
making edits to a specific thing or
something, right?
And then there's like an outcome that
you're trying to maximize in some way
and it can be pretty loose.
And ideally, we want areas where we can
like simulate stuff fast.
So stuff where like we maybe we just
have to like do some sort of pretty
basic sim that only has a few a few
atoms like small molecules that doesn't
need to be like at the fidelity of orca
or something. I don't know. I'm pretty
new to this area. But generally when you
see problems where like you need tons of
data and you can make a fast sim and
there's some element of interaction RL
is a good fit.
I can just build rail five
pretty much. I think we use 5.5 though.
Only thing
uh yeah 2048 crashed with NAMS. That's
unfortunate.
Okay, we'll research it and tell you
about it because in Comp Cam they use
DFT and visualize
results in Avagadro.
Yeah, I can see what you're saying.
Yeah. I'm not familiar with any of the
like the standard
comp chemes,
right? I can learn about stuff. Um,
but ideally we're looking for stuff
where we can like,
you know, maybe we like leverage like
some low-level stuff, right? Maybe we're
not like writing our own FFTs and stuff,
but like ideally we can like kind of
make our own sim and tailor it to RL so
we can make it like super fast for the
RL case cuz like the vast vast majority
of simulation software out there is just
not built with RL in mind.
We're also pretty good at writing fast
sims for reference.
Like if it's going to be something where
it's like ludicrously well optimized,
then no. But like very often we're
pretty dang good at making stuff fast.
I don't think this is just spamming
numbers, right?
Yeah, this is like a decent model.
It's not as good as the other one,
though.
Holy lightning.
I don't know if the camera just showed
that flash, but uh holy
debunked my life idea to use Unity for
RL. Uh they do actually have an ML
Agents thing. It's just not very good.
Yeah. I don't know how you got that,
Georgie, because we are definitely the
one we're giving you is definitely 5.5.
at a slower FP. We'll We'll fix the FPS
right now. One sec. Let me fix the FPS
right now.
Yeah. The thing is if I set the FPS that
load's not responsive.
So what we'll do is we'll set this to
30.
You should at least have puffer lip 3 is
the latest official release.
Okay, I fixed the speed. This feels
responsive now.
This is our training run that we have
here.
I kind of want to set up a cool sweep
for this thing.
It's cool how we like learn more things
all the time from um
all these different M's.
this off.
Yeah. Let's just see what this does, you
know? I'm down. Let's just
see what this does.
Oh, look at this. You see, we actually
have this is solving the game. 2.2
billion steps.
I wonder if it's stable.
I'm going to leave this I'm leaving this
in the background. This will run
overnight.
Chem stuff's a big I don't know.
Well, not chem stuff. I mean the the
robotic stuff is a big I don't know.
There a lot of big I don't knows.
Um we'll let this finish and then if
this does well, we can just put this on
the website which will be sweet.
That'll be the thing for today.
Now, what do we do about the robotics,
man?
MMO 3. Maybe
there's really not much I can do.
Technically, I could run PSGD.
I do that real quick. I may as well set
that up.
Yes,
I don't know, man. Can I just do this?
Okay. This this going that they just
don't have the thing Okay.
Uh, this is better than 2048. This end
right here.
Kind of cool, right?
Actually, this is done really well.
Pro that's almost certainly better at
the game than I am.
I'm actually interested to see what this
learning curve looks like.
That's a pretty good learning curve.
Yeah,
that's actually a really useful
environment.
I mean, I guess we'll see once I sweep
it, right? It's technically it's
possible that like
I did see something that looked kind of
like an error.
No, it looks like it actually does just
take a while to train.
Interesting.
Well, we'll get this on the website
tonight.
Any night else?
Nope.
So, we'll leave that be. And now this is
almost done. And we will take our shiny
new uh 2048 policy. We'll deploy this.
We'll put this on the website and you
all will be able to play with it before
I go to sleep tonight. How's that sound?
Oh, hey Tim.
Georgie, I never know what the hell
you're saying.
It's like it's funny because like
sometimes you make sense and I
understand like you actually know
technical things and then sometimes it's
like what on earth are you doing, man?
Like I could not come up with that
sentence if I tried.
Me actually just put this in the chat.
Who did 2048?
Python and a Windows.
That's what I meant to say.
Doesn't look like it. He's talking about
gzipping tacos, man.
This could use an animation to be fair,
like a swipe animation.
The funny thing is like Georgie's
actually sent me like 3D models and he's
like actually helped me with like uh
some basic like modeling software stuff.
There are a couple like there are a
couple regular viewers who I suspect are
actually LLMs. Georgie is not one of
them. I just something something's up. I
don't know.
Look, for all I know, this is like uh,
you know, come home for the evening,
drop a bunch of acid, and watch tech
streams, right? That would explain it.
For all I know,
whatever. Welcome to the stream, man.
I hope you enjoy.
They needed help from my seekings. See,
that was clever.
web.
Okay, here comes our uh our web
deployment.
So, literally all I do is I export this
thing to a web assembly.
So, I'll let this do this and then I'll
get a screenshot.
See that sentence? I have no idea.
No idea at all.
Why don't you use WebGL? It can do
OpenGL.
Uh the thing that matters is web
assembly.
It's actually it is GLSL.
It's OpenGL like one or whatever for the
rendering on this. Well, for shaders,
the thing that matters is that the sim
code is in C. It's that like the thing
that matters is the sim code is in C.
The rendering is cheap.
It's like whatever the hell what backend
mcripton is using. I don't know some
OpenGL.
actually. Who did 2048?
I have to credit them.
Was it Wooden?
I'll have to double check.
I need to know the width and height of
this.
Almost on the website.
Four minutes.
Which Linux distro are you using? Just
Abuntu.
How's it going, Nat? Welcome to the
stream. You almost have 2048 on the
website with uh a nicely trained agent.
Weird. This doesn't usually happen.
Um
Huh.
Georgie, can stop spamming. Like, what
what are you doing, man?
What What are you doing?
Like, I got no idea what you're doing.
You're just saying things. You're just
saying things to say things.
None of that makes any sense. What are
you doing?
Okay. So, for some reason, I don't know
why this is not loading.
Oh,
it just can't be labeled as a number.
Okay.
As a preview.
Okay. As a preview. This is pretty good as a preview. Yeah.
Okay, whatever. Weird merge. Don't know
what happened there.
What are you doing today? I just joined.
Well, given that it's uh 9:30, you're uh
joining at the uh last bit of the end
here. Today, I was working on getting
Puffer Lib training on a several
different robotics environments. I uh
published this article,
which if you're looking for some new
content around here, this is uh
this is a pretty good short read.
This is on our 640 billion observation
neural MMO training run and how you can
do that.
And then just now I got 2048 from a
contributor. I fixed it up. I got it
running nicely. I fored the network to
see and now it is on the website. Well,
I think it's on the website. Let's see
if it's synced yet.
Yep, there it is. It's on the website.
So, if I hold shift,
I should be able to play. Hang on.
Oh, why can't I play?
Well, this is annoying.
I can't actually play.
The model can play, but I can't, which
is annoying.
Uh, I can play it on my local just fine.
Something is weird's happening here.
Yeah, I can't
and I can't play it. I don't know why.
That's uh guys, you got to copy. You got
to like stick to the template, man.
Can't can't be doing silly [ __ ] like
this.
And now we have the a lovely problem of
not actually knowing whether um
just isn't reloading or it's still not
working.
seem to still not be working, which
would be very
very odd.
really are we uh
sure that this is what's happening.
like I'm going to be very annoyed if
this is just some dumb caching thing.
Doesn't seem to be some dumb caching
though, right?
I actually don't know why this can't be
played.
Let me just look one last time and then
I'm going to bed.
Uh, no. I can't see anything.
Hey man,
I see.
I don't know why this is
Okay, I'm going to send a quick message
on the Discord.
All right. So, we've got uh we've got a
sweep going
on uh 2048 and be back tomorrow. Maybe
more robotics, maybe drone stuff. We
shall see.
Uh yeah, the robotic stuff is like it's
working.
I don't know what we can really do. I
think we're going to just have to like
we're going to have to pace the robotic
stuff because I got other things to do
and the robotics is just really slow. Um
but yeah. Okay. Thank you folks for
tuning in. If you're interested in all
this stuff, it is all on puffer.ai.
uh now complete with
brand new environment that uh we just
got online today with a pretty dang good
agent that plays in your browser.
If you want to help me out for free,
start the GitHub right here.
Really helps us out. You can see the uh
the little uptick since 3.0 just a
little bit. We definitely uh want to see
some growth here. And then if you want
to get involved with dev discord and
then other than that follow me on X for
more reinforcement learning content
where I post a bunch of articles some of
which you can't find anywhere else.
Thanks folks and uh back in the